camera traps are used by the
conservation community
to take inventory of wildlife
populations
and ultimately measure the health of
biodiversity in a non-invasive way
using motion sensor cameras these
cameras take care of automatically
snapping photos
when movement is detected but the tricky
part after is reviewing each of the
millions of photos
and counting each species as well as bad
actors
such as poachers this is where
machine learning is of great help and so
in this episode we will share
how to build an image classification app
for camera traps
so let's dive in
thanks to data today we can understand
our natural world with
far greater richness than ever before by
orders of magnitude
this now empowers us to build amazing
apps that can help us solve
complex social and environmental
challenges
and so in this series let's build an app
together meet tanya from google
where her and a team of volunteers have
done an amazing job
at partnering with multiple
organizations to launch a successful
image classifier for camera traps along
with a web app that lets
anyone upload camera trap data since
it's fundamental in machine learning to
use a lot of data
and so sharing with us many
organizations is essential
to research as many species as possible
you can check out the website at
wildlifeinsights.org
wildlife insights is a project that's a
collaboration between
leading conservation organizations in
google and
the bigger picture challenge that we're
facing is
we've lost 68 percent of wildlife
populations on average since the 1970s
biologists for a number of years about
you know several decades or even
even further have been using these
things called camera traps
this is a motion triggered camera the
animal walks by
and the camera takes a series of images
[Music]
so one of the challenges the data is is
siloed oftentimes
it's in it's housed in universities or
research institutions
um and there there isn't an easy way to
share that data the second problem is
it's really hard to process um like i
said you can be
you know drowning in all of this data
millions and millions of images
and what you really need is the species
of your interest so
we have been working with the google
cloud platform to upload to manage and
share
uh and store all of this camera trap
data millions and millions of images on
the google cloud
and then um we've been applying uh
artificial intelligence models to
understand make predictions upon what
species is in what image
this project is quite amazing and now i
will walk you through how to build a
simple version
let's start with the main ingredients
for the hardware and the software
from a hardware standpoint we need a
camera trap taking photos
that's connected to a microcontroller
like a raspberry pi
or arduino this basically serves
as a small linux computer and will have
an ml model we install
that labels images of species and omits
blank images
if it is able to connect to the internet
via a cellular network
it can send labeled photos automatically
but in remote areas
you can carry the microcontroller to a
wi-fi enabled area periodically to do
this transfer
as a friendly tip when managing a large
fleet of microcontrollers
it's handy to write a script that uses
cloud iot
core in order to update all your devices
simultaneously rather than updating each
device manually especially as the
classification model
is updated with new data from the field
next is the software which we will be
using cloud computing resources from
google cloud
i think one of the biggest um challenges
for this project
uh is building it upon a
robust enough platform that it can scale
and also that can handle the kind of
inference
that we'll be doing when you know you
have biologists from all over the world
that are uploading their data
and using cloud ai platform predictions
for this project specifically the
estimated cost per month
is less than thirty dollars as of the
making of this video
and includes three gigabytes of images
there are two
main workflows in the solution one is a
training model
and the other is classifying images and
the two
products that perform most of the heavy
lifting is dataflow
and ai platform let's start with
dataflow
which is a serverless data processing
service that can process
very large amounts of data needed for
machine learning activities
in this scenario we use it to run two
jobs
the first job creates a database in
bigquery
by uploading two columns of the metadata
from the camera trap data set from lila
diet
science this is a one-time setup those
two columns contain the category of the
label of the species
the other is the file's name or the path
where the image is located
it also emits rows that do not contain
relevant information
which is an essential data
pre-processing step
the second data flow job makes a list of
images
that would be great for creating a
balanced data set
this is informed by our requirements for
selecting
images that have a minimum and a maximum
amount of species per category
to ensure that we train a bias-free
model that doesn't include a species it
has
too little information about and is
later unable to classify it correctly
when this assessment is complete
dataflow proceeds to download the actual
images
into cloud storage from that lila
science dataset i mentioned
this enables us to only store and
process the images that are relevant
and not the entire data set this keeps
computational time and
costs down next we build a model with ai
platform
which uses automl and the images we
store in cloud storage
once the model is deployed we can
classify images
let's see what the model thinks about
some of these images
[Music]
so this is fantastic we have a model
working
now the next step is to upload it to
each microcontroller so that it
classifies
images locally next time you want to
upload these classified images from the
field
we can save them as jpeg files directly
into cloud storage
and their metadata into bigquery
note that you can optionally collect
more metadata information such as the
camera traps location
the date etc and build a simple
dashboard that you can report
aggregated insights of species to recap
wildlifeinsights.org is an amazing
project and today we took apart this
case study in order to inspire you to
try to replicate the solution
for your own use case so what's next
well i have appended in this video's
description
several helpful links including a link
to a notebook that contains all the code
we used for this example
which means you don't have to write any
of it
all you have to do is click play for
each section
and finally you can hit like or leave us
a comment
if you found this content helpful and
share what other ai for good use cases
you have in mind thank you so much for
watching friends
i'll leave you with tania's fun fact
about this project
cheers a fun fact about working on this
project
has been putting a camera trap in my
very own backyard
yeah we've caught all sorts of animals
we've got mountain lions
bobcats foxes deer of course opossums
and yeah it's really great to be able to
teach my kids about
the wildlife in our backyard
you